foreign
question of the day comes from Tony in
Michigan he says I'm 56 years old and
have no debt I have 1.4 million in the
bank and want to know how much is enough
for me to feel comfortable retiring 1.4
million sounds like a lot but I don't
have a good handle on how long that
would last that's a really good question
um David I feel like a lot of people
kind of have that thought in their mind
I've got this money how do I know if
it's enough how do how do I know if I
can retire or when I can retire and I
feel like it's more about being able to
and being happy with living off the
interest so if you looked at 1.4 million
and it's invested let's say that you're
averaging a 10 point 10 percent rate of
return are you able to live on the 10
comfortably with inflation with all of
your expenses so in his case 140 000 a
year
does that feel right if you feel like
yes then great it'll last forever it'll
last forever because you're never
touching the principle yeah nobody
playing the golden eggs that's right and
and that's really where you want to be
you don't ever want to have to touch
that money
um but if you're looking at that and
you're like oh I don't know living on
140 000 I've been living off of 200 if
you've got a house payment there's so
many things to consider but that's
ultimately at the end of the day what we
want to be looking at is living off the
interest and if that's possible for you
so yeah and here's a simple equation and
it is probably overly simple but just to
kind of give you an idea all right
inflation not counting lately or
counting lately actually and for the
last 75 years has averaged four percent
four point two percent
okay now lately we've been closer to 10.
sure and in the 70s where we were 12 but
the average
over the last 75 years is 4.2 all right
now the average stock market rate of
return is 11.8
since the stock market began that's the
average annual return if you had
invested in growth stock mutual funds
across the stock market okay now so if
we just use rough numbers let's say 12
percent rate of return which my personal
mutual funds have averaged that from
decades now so averaged some years not
some years a lot more average that's
right into sixth grade math can you
explain average because I know all the
time people fight us on on that the
difference between annual or like
annualized rate of return looking at it
over the track record of it just just
look at and say what did you make okay
because this is how wealthy people look
at they go all right if I'm making 12
and I'm losing 4 in purchasing power
because of inflation the cost of bread
went up the cost of electricity went up
the cost of cars and tires went up the
cost of dot dot dot went up four percent
so if I'm making 12 and I'm losing four
in purchasing power if I pull off eight
my mutual funds will grow by four a year
but they have to do that to break even
in purchasing power
so if you're earning 12 and pulling off
four you're getting a cost of living
raise every year
but it's a cost of living raise it's not
anymore you're not you're not gaining
actual wealth right it's net of
inflation you're gaining but you're
gaining actual dollars to offset the
inflation okay so if if and if you did
that and if you want to use different
numbers use different numbers use 11 and
and five then you'd pull off six okay I
don't care but that's how you can go
ahead so if you got a million dollars
and you pull off eight that's eighty
thousand that means you made 120 so your
million grew by 40 000 and you lived on
the 80 then so if you can live off of
eight percent and you're invested in
good mutual funds you'll probably pretty
much do it in perpetuation
um it might dip into it a little and it
might refill in another year yeah but
overall it'll pretty much run it'll
pretty much run like a machine the rest
of your life assuming that the you know
the American economy continues to do
what it has done for the last 80 years
well this is one of those reasons it's
so important to do what we teach pay off
your debt pay off your mortgage so that
when you're going into retirement your
ex your cost of living is not Sky High
right and let me tell you something else
here there are some really stupid people
that write Financial articles all over
the Internet and here's here's what's
stupid about them all right they run all
these numbers out in great detail on
math and they do not grasp that life
will never
ever happen the way they laid it out so
the way we just laid this out do you
think that that you got the chances that
guys 1.4 million that he's going to live
on exactly 140 or exactly eight percent
of that right which would be more like a
hundred okay is he actually going to do
it exactly that way are those mutual
funds going to earn exactly a market
rate of return are they going to make a
little more or a little less that's
right what's going to actually happen is
he's probably going to live on less than
that and this money is going to grow and
there's some other factors that we
haven't even considered in this like his
life and his health and his marriage and
you know and inheritance comes or
doesn't come in addition to this there's
all kinds of other crap that's going to
happen and so these guys when they're
writing these Financial articles act
like well I mean if you miss this by
point two percent you're not going to
make it you're you can't estimate this
you can't forecast it within 0.2 percent
if you're you know unless you're God you
don't know what's going to happen right
and I promise you God is Not not writing
Financial articles
on Tic Tac okay it's definitely not
happening so I can tell because the
people doing it are idiots and God's
fairly smart so the point is these guys
are become such math nerds they think
all this stuff operates in an exact
little vacuum and it never works out
that way I mean can you imagine if today
with you know I've got hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of real estate
today
that was none of that was in my equation
right
none of it yeah I mean so I mean all you
had to do is like be one piece of real
estate off that's right and the whole
thing changes so you know you're in one
way or the other one business that you
sell yeah or that uh has a hit and Booms
uh one little thing so you can't you're
30 years old you can't predict when
you're 70 exactly where you're going to
be but you can have a Target that's
right and say based on that Target I
know that if I'm 25 years old and I
average 12 percent and I put a hundred
dollars a month away from age 25 to age
65 that the math tells me that's one
million 176 thousand dollars is it going
to happen exactly that way I just said
it wasn't
but that's what the math can predict for
you it can go oh so we could have over a
million dollars we have hope we're not
going to wait on uh Karl Marx and
socialism to fix this right we're
actually going to work and save and live
on less than we make and be on a budget
and keep our butts out of debt this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]